[музика]
Віталій хронюк пішов захищати Україну
добровольцем у лютому торік за майже рік
повномасштабної війни він зрозумів що
мріє про велику родину В мене такі були
відчуття коли там обстріл і ти просто
лежиш молишся Богу і ти молишся щоб
вижити але і ти в цей момент думаєш блін
Так хочеться щоб дитина була залишилась
щоб і кохана якби
після себе залишитись Віталій вирішив
скористатися послугою кріоконсервації
заморозки чоловічої сперми завдяки цьому
його дружина Анна зможе скористатися
біоматеріалом свого партнера поки він
буде на фронті або ж якщо із ним щось
станеться дівчині було складно звикнути
до думки про те що чоловік може не
повернутися але врешті вона погодилася з
його рішенням якщо жінка чи дівчина
втратить свого коханого чоловіка То в
неї буде потім можливість коли вона там
говтається Хоча я розумію що від цього
дуже тяжко буде говтатися але в неї буде
сенс для того щоб продовжувати боротися
продовжувати жити і все-таки вона буде
носити собі частину свого коханого
ембріологія Оксана Лизогуб досліджує
зразок людської ферми цей біоматеріал
готують до заморозки або ж
кріозбереження але насамперед треба
оцінити якість що активніше рухаються
сперматозоїди то краще
заморожена сперма зберігається у таких
діарах з рідким азотом при температурі
мінус 196 градусів за Цельсієм
ми морозимо суспензію сперматозоїдів
тобто в таких пробірочках вона може
зберігатись не обмежено довго головне
підливати азот і слідкувати за
кредобанком поки буде азот поки буде
зберігатися на властивості ніяк не
впливає тривало зберігання у цій клініці
зберігаються кілька тисяч зразків
замороженої сперми жіночий оцити і
навіть ембріони здебільшого свій
біоматеріал віддають на кріозбереження
люди які планують ставати батьками
згодом але хочуть зберегти молоді
статеві клітини а також пацієнти з
тяжкими хворобами лікування яких
призводить до безпліддя протягом
останнього року до клініки також почали
звертатися військові тут теж чоловіки в
таких ситуаціях які складні яка може
вплинути на їхню фертильність і якщо
вона вплине погано вони використовують
цю сперму якщо чоловік помре його
дружина може використати сперму його Ну
ми сподіваємося що так буде
і народити спільну дитину з чоловіком
якого вона кохала в нас армія дуже крута
і в нас туди йдуть дуже розумні люди
дуже
класними генами Якщо так можна сказати
Мені здається що вони мають
продовжуватися ну тобто вони мають
продовжуватися в своїх дітях це дуже
важливо для України
залишити цих людей
для розвитку нашої держави військова
Ярина Чорногуз нині на передовій на
напрямку Сватове Кремінна дівчина
замислюється над тим аби разом з
чоловіком віддати свій біоматеріал на
заморозку
моїм чоловіком майбутньому має як свої
переваги та
постійно переживання одне залежного
настрою
коли ми були такі ситуації що
розуміються це можуть бути в останніх
хвилинах
писали нам поки що щастить
а і так ми це з ним про це говорили і
ось навіть миркуємо що наступного разу
як у нас виключать або пару днів
то можливо ми навіть Ярина визнає серед
військових тема заморозки сперми і
яйцеклітин не надто популярна Утім після
півтора року служби на передовій
військово зрозуміла що для неї важливо
думати про майбутнє
наших найкра людей чоловіків і жінок
мені доводилось що втрачати близьку
людину
серйозні стосунки
так само я бачила
сховались підрозділі хлопці та загиблих
лишилися молоді дружини дівчата
майже від усіх книг Я чула цей цю саму
англійську бо я знала як народила чому
так не так хотіла як би мала йому давай
мені після війни після перемоги стикаюся
з тим що ну зараз піду про людину крім
як твоїй пам'яті більше
репродуктологиня Ксенія Жиленко відкрила
свою клініку у грудні 2022 року відтоді
до неї вже звернулися 10 про військових
один із чоловіків разом з дружиною
замовили кріоконсервацію ембріона інші
заморозили сперму у багатьох війна може
забрати можливість мати дітей
обмороження ну якби це все об'єктивні
речі
але найбільш часто насправді функція
страждаючої з поранення ну якби це не
секрет для армії тих країн які давно
воюють що це найбільша причина причина
не несприятливі умови чоловічі
фертильність влаштована таким чином що
все ж таки після потрапляння сприятливі
умови все ж таки частіше відбувається
відновлення у жінок воно до речі все
складніше вот але там де йдеться про
поранений на жаль це все не відворотнє
вже і там покращення не буде для
чоловіків заморозка сперми нескладна
процедура потрібно лише здати аналізи на
інфекційні хвороби І власне сам
біоматеріал у столичних клініках усе це
коштує від трьох до восьми тисяч гривень
але для військових у низці медзакладів
Києва і заморозка ізберігання протягом
першого року безкоштовні для жінок
військових пільг поки не пропонують адже
забір яйцеклітин набагато складніший
його вартість до 70 тисяч гривень
заморожування клітин трошечки інші по
сутності свої тому що воно вимагає
підготування ну такого інтенсивного
підготування для жінки Вона готується
медикаментами спеціальними і цей процес
він не страшний але він ресурсний в
плані часу
медикаментозного навантаження
фінансового типу тому що медикаменти
якими проводиться підготування вони не
дешеві ще один нюанс що стосується і
чоловіків і жінок юридичний адвокат
Сергій Антонов пояснює і в Україні і в
більшості держав світу крім консервація
ніяк не готуються законодавством на
практиці повернутися по своїй статеві
клітини і використати їх потім зазвичай
не проблема А ось якщо власник
біоматеріалу помирає тобто потрібна
посмертна репродукція юридичну ситуацію
складніша на законодавстві також є такі
така прохалина що у нас незрозуміла хто
саме з родичів тобто першого ступеня
Різдва чи другу ступеня Різдва може
вирішити питання якщо в них наприклад
конфлікти інтерес наприклад батьки
хочуть а дружина не хоче тобто
відповідно що можемо навіть подати позов
чи в тому ж судовому процесі що Вона
заперечує потрібно
за юристами обговорити як кращі діяти
тобто якщо це наприклад програма
підкладена у батьківство коли за життя
то робиться То може прописати
відповідний Хм документи зокрема заяви
про те що конкретне навіть визначається
кому можна бути використати так як
використовувати укласти договір з
медичним за поїздом в якому прописати
щоб у випадку смерті
медичний заклад зобов'язується передати
психологиня Антоніна картушинська
консультує пари які вдаються до
кріоконсервації вона радить підходити до
планування народження дітей
відповідально надто Якщо в одного з
батьків є ризик загинути тут більше
дорослих про те що там я тебе кохаю якщо
я в тебе втрачаю то я хочу мати часку
тебе А дійсно дитина
буде виховуватись не в повній сім'ї де
відсутні наприклад батько да але ж це
значить що
дитину не будуть любити вона не отримує
належного виховання перше - це
індивідуальна потреба Тобто це потреба
індивіда коли я хочу Да я хочу Я готовий
і друга потреба - це видова потреба виду
тобто Мені потрібно тоді це звучить да
Тобто це продовження виду тобто я хочу
продовжити ось цій дитині Да я хочу щоб
ми там продовжили в цій дитині Це трошки
і тому зараз коли
війна коли активний бойові дії потреба в
дітях актуалізуються саме з цією видовою
потреби тобто продовжити вид і залишити
по собі слід і відродитись дитині
фахівці з репродуктології застерігають
що війна лише загострить демографічну
кризу в Україні і радять замислитися про
майбутнє вже нині на передовій це
розуміють як ніде люди
сподіваються на краще сподіваються що з
ними нічого не ставляться що їм
пощастить ну Віра Надія завжди живуть
коли ти це робиш Ти ніби маєш визнати
думку що з тобою можна щось статися
Можеш або загинути або отримати
від цього треба зробити певні
запобіжники якось планувати планувати
свою загибель не всі це можуть